The most effective methods to get ideas across
in cinema are usually the subtlest ones. Rather
than characters stating ideas on religion
and social commentary through dialogue, these
messages are better expressed through allegories,
metaphors, and symbols that infer subliminal
meanings in the viewer.
Here are 10 Secret Subliminal Messages In
Famous Movies
Star Wars
While it may be easy to say any film with
a quote unquote “chosen one” is based
on the story of Jesus, there’s much more
than that in Star Wars that reinforces Christian
beliefs and teachings. For example, Anakin
demonstrates several of the deadly sins, particularly
pride and anger, which set him on the path
to the dark side. Despite his terrible sins,
Luke never loses faith in his father and Anakin
ultimately redeems himself by sacrificing
his life for his son’s. It was Luke’s
strong faith and forgiveness that saved his
own life and his father’s immortal soul.
Preach it George.
The Departed
When the characters start dropping like flies
in The Departed, you really begin to feel
like anyone could be next. However there are
visual cues placed throughout that let you
know which characters are going to get nixed.
Scorsese placed X’s throughout the film,
usually appearing behind characters who have
an axe over their head. This is no coincidence,
especially when you consider that one never
appears behind Dignam, who’s pretty much
the only one who gets out alive. This is also
Scorsese’s nod to Howard Hawks Scarface,
a 1932 film in which an X appears onscreen
whenever a murder is about to occur.
The Shining
If you break it down, The Shining is probably
one of the densest horror film ever made.
Kubrick crafted a layered film that has inspired
hundreds of interpretations and theories,
some more far fetched than others. One that
many seem to agree on is the underlying theme
of the European’s genocide against Native
Americans that has gone unpunished. It’s
mentioned early on that the hotel was built
over an Indian burial ground, an offence they
seem proud of as images of native americans
and native american art are placed throughout
the hotel. Kubrick placed subtle references
to the country’s first inhabitants in everything
from set decoration, to wardrobe, to the score.
Some of have see the buckets of blood pouring
from the elevator as literally bringing up
the past buried below the hotel. It’s also
no coincidence that the final image shows
jack ata July 4th celebration, the holiday
that best represents the European’s false
claim of the land.
The Wizard of Oz
At the outset, it seems like The Wizard of
Oz is a film that would fall nicely in line
with many Christian beliefs. Dorothy and her
friends follow a clear path to receive enlightenment
from a god-like figure. However when it’s
revealed that the Wizard’s a fake, some
saw this as a critique on faith and the worship
of false gods. In the mid 80s, a group of
Christian fundamentalist in Tennessee even
tried to get the book banned from the school
curriculum because it suggests that humanity’s
strength comes from within instead of being
handed down by god. While some consider the
Wizard of Oz a case for atheism, others claim
to have actually SEEN God while watching the
film synced up with Pink Floyd’s Dark Side
of the Moon.
X Men
If you ever wonder why the X Men movies often
get caught up in the politics of Mutant Rights,
that’s because the issues facing these characters
and how people treat them are meant to mirror
actual experiences of marginalized groups,
particularly the LGBT community. It’s an
issue that hits close to home for director
Brian Singer, who included scenes of mutants
“coming out” to parents who react with
fear and anger. Their powers usually manifest
around the same time as puberty, causing many
young mutants to feel shame and conceal their
abilities. Colonel Stryker is the best example
of the prejudices and mutant-phobia that run
rampant in this world. When so many have been
forced to live a lie, you can see why characters
like Magneto are angry with the treatment
of mutants and fight for worldwide Mutant
Pride.
Aliens
In the same way Ridley Scott brought the horror
genre into space with the first Alien, James
Cameron set his sci sequel apart by bringing
the Vietnam war into space. For Aliens, Cameron
created fear and unease by using imagery that
subliminally recalled images of America’s
unpopular war. Once the government sends in
the marines, the over armed, over confident,
trigger happy soldiers quickly become scared
sitting ducks. Much of the action plays out
over monitors as others look on helplessly.
Vietnam is sometimes referred to as The Television
War because it was the first war people could
watch unfold on TV. In the end the massive
casualties were the fault of the corrupt politicians
who sent the ill prepared soldiers there.
We’ll leave it up to you to decide if that
last point was about the movie or the war.
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hollows
When the Harry Potter books and films were
first gaining popularity, some religious groups
boycotted it for celebrating the occult and
witchcraft. However, those who stuck with
the series all the way to the end could see
clear parallels between the story’s hero
and Jesus Christ. Harry has humble beginnings
yet is told from a very young age that he’s
“the chosen one”. In the Deathly Hollows
part 2, Potter sets out on his own quest in
the wilderness where he overcomes temptation.
In the end he accepts that he must sacrifice
himself for the greater good and is struck
down. He visits a heavenly place and speaks
with a wise bearded man in white before returning
to his earthly body and defeating evil. Apparently
when looking for ways to conclude Harry’s
saga, J.K. Rowling looked no further than
the greatest story ever told.
The Matrix Reloaded
If you’ve studied The Matrix, you know that
nothing that made it into those final movies
is there by mistake. In The Matrix Reloaded,
eagle eye viewers may have noticed that Agent
Smith pimped out his ride with some sweet
vanity plates. ‘IS 5416’ might just look
like random letters and numbers, but good
Christians will know that this is a reference
to the Bible, Isaiah 54:16 which reads “Behold,
I Myself have created the smith who blows
the fire of coals And brings out a weapon
for its work; And I have created the destroyer
to ruin.” This is basically Agent Smith’s
Ezekiel 25:17, it sounds cool but a bit long
to fit onto a license plate.
The Truman Show
Do you ever feel like some omniscient begin
is watching over your every move? Some call
this feeling God, but if you’ve seen The
Truman Show, you’ve probably imagined an
Ed Harris-like producer overseeing and orchestrating
your life’s events at some point. While
on the surface it’s a film about voyeurism
and reality TV, The Truman show also brilliantly
incorporated deeper ideas of free will and
God’s plan. Truman questions Ed Harris’
all seeing show runner and defies his plan,
thereby achieving personal freedom. What begins
as a light comedy, actually turns into a subliminally
subversive narrative that could have people
doubting their own beliefs. In The Truman
Show, God turns out to be just another man
behind a curtain.
Captain America: The Winter Soldier
If you’ve ever heard conspiracy theorists
throw around names of organizations like Illuminati
and New World Order and wonder what the heck
they’re talking about, then look no further
than Hydra in Captain American: Winter Soldier.
When the filmmakers decided to take inspiration
from political thrillers, a secret agency
with tentacles in high levels of government
made for the perfect villain. Like Hydra,
many believe the Illuminati to be tied to
post-war Nazism and is made up some of the
most powerful people in the world who secretly
manipulate everything. It’s been said they
even employ mind control tactics. Pierce’s
line in Winter Soldier about a tearing the
old world down to create a better one is basically
the basis for what people refer to as the
New World Order. What’s fact and what’s
fiction here remains to be seen.
These are just a few examples we found of
subtle messages hidden our favourite movies.
What movie made you look at things differently?
Let us know in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe for more videos like this.